Hey, what's going on is bill burn?
It's time for the Thursday afternoon.
Just before Friday.
Monday morning podcast and Ah,
ah,
yes. Checking in on you. Uh, March 29th.
Oh my God. This month is almost, oh,
did you have a good month?
Well, that's good. Um,
I just have so much stuff to talk about.
I don't even know where to begin.
First of all,
last night I watched the
first hour and a half of that,
the zen of Garry Shandling,
the Judd Apatow documentary on
the great genius Gary Shandling.
And I'm, I got to tell you, judge,
did that Guy Proud? It's unbelievable.
You have to see it. A comedian buddy
of mine told me, he goes, dude,
have you seen this thing yet?
You got to see it.
Thank God he told me about it and I
went and I recorded this goddamn thing,
you know, and I'm telling you right
now, you got to see him. All right?
I told you last week
you have to watch Barry.
If you sat down and you watched
Barry Storing Bill Hader, uh,
Henry Winkler and all those
guys, uh, you know, I was right.
Okay.
When are you gonna learn to trust when
I tell you something on HBO is going to
be good. Um, anyways,
I was watching that documentary and I
guess Gary Shandling just kept diaries.
His whole life was basically his entire
life and he was writing all this stuff
and overcoming fear and trying to
get better as a comedian and a,
it was like Erie watching,
like how much I related to it because
I never kept a diary. I tried one time,
I was just too walled off emotionally.
I remember I wrote like one line,
my name's bill,
I'm 28.
I'm a stand up comedian
and that's as far as I got.
And then I think I threw that book out
so it's biodegrading somewhere cause it's
made out of paper. Um, but anyways,
I used to always, I would write
down on cocktail Napkins, dad,
right. Commit to everything, be positive.
I actually used that thing, you know,
in the Catholic Church,
I can't remember the part of the mass
where you do the sign of the cross on your
forehead, your mouth and then over
your heart, which means you know,
God in your mind, you and your mouth
and in your heart or something stuff.
Like I used it as like a positive
side rather than, you know,
God's only son died on this thing that
I'm now fucking drawing on my face.
I actually, I use it as like a positive
side, like no negative thoughts.
Um, I don't know why I thought
I'd put a positive sign of,
of my mouth so much to the Shit I
say is fucking curmudgeony at best.
But it was just more just
committing to everything. And um,
cause when we first moved down to New
York, it was intimidating thing. And uh,
I get on my heels and
then I wouldn't have a,
and then I'd have to
wait like another five,
six days before get stage time again,
just fucking hating myself for going
up there and acted like a little guy.
Um, although you're not supposed to say
that now, right? That's not progressive.
You know why you saying that? You're
acting like a little girl. Okay. Okay.
I was acting like a,
somebody who's gender neutral.
Why can't you just say that she was
scared without insulting the opposite sex?
Well, I don't know, I guess, you
know, I guess I guess said something.
I need to work on there.
I happy. Yeah. Okay. Kay,
can you shave your legs?
Um,
AH, fuck. I have fun. Last night on
stage, man, I went up and I was just,
I'm sick of a bunch of shit
in my act and I was just like,
I'm not talking about any of that shit.
And I just meandered,
meandered is the key word there. But I
had a good time. I apologize to the crowd,
but I, you know what units? It was
a fucking Wednesday. All right.
Wednesday's a work day. Um, but anyways,
it's a wonderful week.
It's a wonderful week in Los Angeles.
Nothing's on fire.
No one got me to evidentaly.
They got all the crepes.
Um,
all right. Oh, I got to promote
here. Bar still rough and rowdy.
If you've missed the last few podcasts,
first of all,
it's one of the great paper
views you're ever going to watch.
It's just regular people
that enjoy fighting.
They want to get on TV and they are
willing to fight each other. Okay.
It's like, I don't know, I don't
even know how to describe it. It's a,
it's a juggernaut and it's like 15,
16 bucks and a,
I'm going to be at the next one and I
will be ringside announcing even though I,
I bet, I know the jab is, I know
what a hook is. Overhand, right.
I know what a straight writers too,
cause I watched the documentary, uh,
leap boom by, yeah, I watched that a
long time ago. But other than than that,
I'm just going to be making fun of Shit.
Like I always do.
And hopefully one of those regular people
won't try to beat the crap out of me
afterwards. Um, I dunno. I'm
so fucking excited for it.
And uh, that's going to
be on April 13th. Okay.
You guys, I'm telling you, I, I'm, I'm,
I'm telling you, you got to fucking see.
You got to see the shit. You
know, you don't have to, you know,
if you want to miss out and then not
know what anybody's talking about.
Come Monday when you standing
around the fucking water cooler.
Um, and, uh, this is the last
promo thing I have to do. Um,
we've added some shows.
If you want an updated list of the
shows to see possibly come and see my
ignorance live, uh, go to bill bird.com.
Dot Events for an updated list of shows.
I hate doing promos in the beginning
of the podcast because it just kills my
fucking flow, you know, now I
just feel like I don't, you know,
like I'm sitting in a fucking waiting
room. I don't feel funny anymore.
I don't know who I am. Um,
oh, here's one for you.
The theme of this podcast,
this half hour is, is,
is late to the party. All right? And,
um, which is really a
theme to my life. Okay.
I was late for everything.
You know,
I stayed back in first
grade. Boom, right there.
I was just a year behind my
whole fucking life. All right.
I wasn't late getting my driver's license.
I got that thing immediately.
The day I was eligible.
I did the old right there.
Fred took it on a stick shift too.
It's one of the main,
that's probably the only manly
thing I've ever done in my life.
I had no choice. That's all
we had in our, in our family.
We always had sticks shifts. Um,
cause they were fucking cheap.
Um,
also it's more fun.
You fell you'd drive in the fucking car
instead of just getting in some go cart
down there. I hate automatic
transmission. You know,
there's only a few left out there.
I think the, uh, the Volkswagen Gti,
there's one or two BMWs is probably a
Porsche. That's something interesting.
There is something that I could look up.
How many standards?
Standard treads mission
cars left in pro duction.
All right.
The disappearing stick shift.
Less than 3% of cars sold in the
u s still have a stick shift.
All right.
2017 cars that still offer
a manual transmission.
Let's see what we got here.
Well, we have is slow Internet
by the way. My buddy called me
up and you know I have a deli,
missed this amazing Celtics road trip
where they went for no coming in there.
The walking wounded, everybody's out
and all the young kids is stepping up.
And last night they played
the Utah Jazz and I guess, uh,
was a Jaylen brown almost said Jalen
rose hit a three point and a winning.
I heard Jason Tatum stepped up. Uh, I'm
sure I'm missing it. I'm missing by,
I have to miss it. I got the
kid, I got the kids. So I, uh,
if you guys want to know what's going on
with the new episodes of muppet babies,
I'm on. I'm on that. All right.
Gonzo Baby Gonzo had some little chicks
and in the beginning of the episode,
Foz a little Fozzie bear
is doing is bad jokes.
And he went to open his mouth
and it sounded like a fart noise.
And somebody goes, hey, you should say,
excuse me. And I was like, Holy Shit.
Is this going to be about passing gas
and how you handle that in a public forum
like this really progress compared to
the shit that I saw as a kid. You know,
it was just the alphabet.
They didn't deal with bodily functions,
but that wasn't the point far as he goes.
I didn't make that noise and they looked
up and they saw that there was all
these geese were flying
south for the fucking winner.
So then God so got all
fucking afraid that chickens,
we're going to fly south in.
Selfishly,
even though chickens don't fly
south south for the winter,
they're doing it for survival.
But selfishly Gonzo is so fucking needy.
He tries to, you know, keep hiding the
chicken so that the mother, it's weird.
It's like they're all little
fucking puppet animals and
then there's like a real
person that kind of takes care of
them and bring some lunch and shit.
There's like this sort of like,
I don't know what's going on there.
Some sort of muppet beastiality that
this woman had all of these kids,
I have no idea.
You know,
and evidently fucked a frog and a bear
and all kinds of ship or it, I don't know.
One of them is hers a pig.
So anyways,
I'll fucking episode this.
Goddamn, I don't know what he is.
He's like a a vulture.
Maybe
I'm a two can,
I don't know what he is.
He's trying to hide these fucking
chickens. And in the end, uh, the mom,
you know, the, uh, the
puppet groupie there,
she comes out and she says like,
listen,
you're dumb little fuck chickens
do not fly south for the winter.
They're going to be in the coop.
They're going to be fine.
And then Gonzo is all happy in.
What upset me was that the
chickens didn't get mad at him.
In the end, they should have
been like, wait a minute,
she'll like for your own selfish needs,
we would have fucking starved to
death just because you're, you're,
you're so fucking codependent.
And then of course he would try to talk
his way out of it being like, well,
I mean it doesn't really make a difference
cause you don't fly south anyways.
He says, yeah, yeah, but you
didn't know that digit guides up.
You didn't know that
and you will fucking contend.
What the fuck are we going to stay
outside the fucking snow. You can't.
You're crooked. Bigged cunt.
And then God's, I'll be like,
I always knew that you thought I was
less than other people fight and then he
would make it about his fucking
nose. See, that's why you can't,
you got to stay on topic because I just
fucked up the argument for the chickens.
Don't make fun of his beak. You keep
it on, on, on topic. I should say.
He keep it on fucking topic about the
fact that you're a codependent cycle and
you had information that you knew that
as far as you knew was pertinent to my
own fucking survival. And you kept that
to yourself, didn't you? You little cunt.
So that's the shit that I've been
watching. Um, I know the Bruins it there,
they were doing well and what
are the, see, what have I done?
What have they been doing? They lost
in a shootout to Columbus five, four.
They lost in overtime to one to St
Louis. So there's two points. We go,
we beat Dallas. There's four points
for that week. Four of a possible six.
I'd say that's a good week.
And then this week we beat Minnesota.
And over time that's two points.
Then we lost in a shootout to win a pig.
Uh,
so we've got three out of
four points cruising along.
Yeah.
Now we've got a couple of home
games against the Florida teams,
the Tampa Bay lightning and
the new fucking a broad street,
the Southbridge speech bullies and the
Florida panthers with the most fighting
fucking mansion in the league.
I mean,
I think they, uh, I think they're almost
going to have 30 fights this year. I mean,
those people are out of control.
Oh, it's fucking assholes.
They all wrote,
they all ruined the Goddamn game.
That was fucking constant watch
Olympic hockey. Not even them.
I can't even blame them.
It's just people that aren't
content with being millionaires.
They want to be billionaires
and now they have to fucking,
let's just level it out.
Let's mainstream it up.
Let's alienate our core fucking fed base.
Yeah.
And try to get all these fucking
douchebags that watch the Kardashians to
fucking watch rivalry, rivalry
Wednesdays, which they're not going to do.
All right. And the theme,
this is good. Everyone.
Did you guys write in and tell me how,
you know,
let me hear your late to the
party stories. I got married
late. I had a kid late.
I started stand up leg. I stayed
back in school. I got laid lake.
Yeah. I fucking had go to summer school.
I was just always, everybody, every,
everybody was always like turning
the corner. I was always like,
why not?
Weird for me.
MMM.
I become progressive.
Like
yeah.
My ideas of, of, of, of of everything
else is like from fucking 20 years ago.
So here's another thing that I am,
I am 30 fucking years late.
I am so late to the party on this
band that they're actually doing their
farewell tour and half the people aren't
even in the band anymore to what are
the first two original members?
So,
mmm.
Doing the goddamn comedy jam and all of
that and like trying to do, you know,
pat terror and learn these,
these double bass drum songs.
Uh, now I, and then, uh, my Trump teacher,
Dave took me to go see miss sugar.
All of a sudden that whole
world opened up to me.
So now I'm backtracking to all of
this shit that I vaguely remember.
My younger brothers, they were into it
go going, you got to hear this shit.
And I was listening to a ribose has it.
So
it's like a that edits.
No,
just that a cow.
Oh,
you know, you're singing along. Six is
say, say that's a good fucking song.
I listening to that shit.
And uh,
when Metallica and all these other bands
came out, it was so fucking fast. I,
I just,
my ear couldn't catch up with it.
And now I'm going back
30 years fucking late. I,
so guess what album I fight
downloaded yesterday? Slayer,
south of heaven. I was
watching, I don't know how I,
I just was watching, like trying to learn,
you know, all this double Bass Shit.
I was just on this youtube thing.
And then eventually if
you're going to do that shit,
eventually you're gonna run into Dave
Lombardo and slayer. So it was like,
I got to fucking see that.
I go why?
I watched this mini documentary I guess
is a new documentary coming out on him.
So I watched this older
one from like 2004 and um,
I've always tried to get into
the band and it was just always,
it was just was beyond
what my ears understood.
So I heard that song south
to heaven and that's it.
I'm done.
So I love that album.
And I guess that was an album they play,
made a conscious effort to play a little
slower than they did on the previous
album. That's the one that
has like angel of death.
And I listened to that one a little bit
now is like the south they have and I'm
going to fucking, I got to, I
can't go from like, you know,
listening to poison and Bon Jovi and
all this shit that I listened to to
immediately going into that level
of speed. You know, that's like,
that's like when he's sober person
after 20 years decides to start partying
again and they pick up
where they left off,
you're going to have a
fucking heart attack.
So I have to kind of ease my way into it
and this fucking album, which I guess,
you know,
Moron fans of musical fresh,
it's not fast enough,
like saying like, that doesn't
even make sense. It's like,
is it a good fucking song?
So I have just been listening to south
of Heaven and whatever the song is after
it,
because they do that thing where it just
sort of blends into it and it's fucking
hilarious.
I'm going to be 50 in June and I'm
finally listening to slayer and up driving
down the street,
pulling up to red lights.
I got it. I fucking love it. So, uh,
late to the party on
that one 30 years late.
And I know I'm going to listen to this
fucking album a million times and then
I'm going to get a angel of death.
And I remember a long time ago I had that,
uh, I had the, uh, the,
the Iowa album. Oh,
what's the name of the band there?
Jesus Christ with Jody Jordan said,
and all those guys, eight, seven
check debt. Thec five bore.
The fuck is in now. Jesus Christ. Don't
say that. I almost said no, they were,
they were the mass. They were the eyes
watch. Ah, fucking what am asshole.
You know what I mean? Listen, I know
who the big four hours anthrax, anthrax,
slayer. Megadeath Metallica. I at least
know that. Okay. I'm an I'm new to this.
Please. Please be gentle when you trash
me on social media for not knowing,
uh,
shit.
Thrash Iowa masks.
Let's see what this comes up with.
Why can't I know the name of the
drummer but not the name of the band,
but the fuck does that say about me?
Huh? Oh, speaking of which I did the,
I did the goddamn comedy jam.
Um,
okay, so now they're showing me slip.
Not Fuck. That's right. That's
right. Okay. It's funny, the
first thing that came up,
why these 11 bands wear masks?
I Dunno, cause they're smart.
They want to have a life
after this show's over.
Okay.
Oh, that's the best thing ever. Like
that bucket head. It's fucking genius.
He gets to fucking go around the world
and guns and roses and all these awesome
beds. And then the second he doesn't
feel like being that guy anymore.
He just takes the bucket off his head
and the mass goes away. You know,
probably puts it up in a man
bun or something. Looks is
non rock. God is possible.
It just fucking walks away like what's
his face at the end of the usual
suspects,
you know,
straightens out his foot and just
walks right through the crowd.
No one has any fucking idea. Um, anyway,
so I did the goddamn comedy jam.
Uh,
thanks everybody. You know, I
played the, uh, I played, uh,
was it Panthera cowboys from hell
and uh,
I thought I had it down. I thought I knew
what I was doing. I got out there, my
Vinnie Paul Costume, I, I actually, I
almost said postmate it, I fucking, uh,
instagrammed it. I grabbed
it. Yolo, my young again.
Um,
the costume that I wore and uh,
that was probably the best part of the
performance was the costumes looking
asshole. You know, Vinny, he's, you
know, he's a Husky fellow, right?
So I had like a pillow or a throw pillow
underneath is this fucking shirt and
like a fucking asshole. When I
sat down behind the drums, like I,
I didn't take it off.
I sat there,
so it was like I had a kid or something
sitting on my lap and the snare was a
little lower than I was used to.
So I fucking got through the song.
I think I fucked up every
single Phil and I got that.
Am I already suck at drums?
Why would you add to difficulty with a
pillow and your fucking chest and this
thing up? You know why?
Because it's the comedy jam.
There has to be some sort of comedy.
So I just look,
my double bass playing still whole fucking
thing sucks. So then the closer was,
um,
was a def Leppard pour some sugar on me,
which was a song that
I absolutely fucking,
and not necessarily because it was a bad,
it's a pop song for what it is.
It's a great fucking song.
But here's the reason why I hated it
was because in 1988 my buddy got that
fucking tape.
Okay.
And all he did was listened to
that fucking song. Like why don't,
can we listen to animal? Can listen to
hysteria? No, no. He just kept fucking,
I remember the time,
he didn't really know the lyrics,
but anytime I would get
to pour some sugar on me,
he'd be like pumping his fist pause.
So was doing the song right
and thank Christ we got out of the middle
part where there's all that busy bass
drum shit that, ah Ha,
well that old shit, right?
We got through all of that,
that whole breakdown thing.
And then we're right in the end and I go
to hit the bass drum and no sound comes
out of the bass drum. And
I'm like, what the fuck?
And I looked down and my bass drum Beta
had fallen off right in the middle of
the fucking saw. So fortunately I
had the double pedal, so I just,
I just played the, the left one for the
rest of the song. Nobody really noticed,
um, until they got to the end of the
song. And I had to do all my, my songs,
fillers and I had nothing. Oh, it's
Paul [inaudible]. Ladies and gentlemen,
welcome to the podcast.
Mr. Paul Versey.
Paul,
can you hear me?
Hey Dude, I'm doing, I'm doing my
podcast. Somebody call you back.
I'll be done in about 15.
All right, let's see. Um,
you know, so that, that all
of that shit happened. So I
had such fucking, I hope so.
I'm like, I'm going to fucking
murder this song. And I did in a,
in a bad way. I butchered
it. Um, but my standup set,
the thing that actually do for a living
was actually really fun and it was fun
to go out there. I wasn't really
being Vinnie Paul, I was just acting.
I was just speaking in a southern accent
and I was talking positively about Ar
15,
which is such a fun thing to do,
um,
in Hollywood
is to dress like a cowboy and then say
why you love Ar 15. So I mean, why,
why wouldn't, why wouldn't
you do that? All right.
So anyways, late to the
party, got into parent,
Tara could have seen them live. My younger
brothers were going to go see them.
I was like, Eh. [inaudible] I
think I'm okay. I think Mr Right.
And I didn't go see them.
Uh,
you know,
just, I don't know when the, when
the fuck did the 1990, they came out,
we're talking, I am literally 30.
I'm 30 years behind the fucking
30 years late.
Wherever the party was.
Like the fucking building doesn't even
exist anymore. How fucking late I am.
All right. Continuing, continuing with
the late to the party fucking theme here.
All right.
I finally watched the first moto GP
race and Qatar's that say it and I gotta
tell you something. Okay. For those of
you not into it. That is a professional,
uh,
motorcycle racing at its highest level.
It's the formula one of motorcycle racing.
And I have to tell you
something right now.
I don't know why I have to tell you that.
I'm going to tell you something.
I should just fucking, you know, cause I
watched friends, Mcdermott Dermot, right?
I'm going to say something,
right.
I'm going to say something
that fucking sport.
I'm
completely fucking sold on it.
I am a big fan of Andre de Vizios.
So who drives the Ducati and
Italian? Right? I just fucking,
I like love the way rides.
I know Mark Marquez is like the
fucking Derek Jeter or this sport.
So whenever I get into a new sport,
you know, it's like Lewis Hamilton.
I'm not going to come into, you know, oh,
this is my first year of watching
Formula One, my favorite drivers,
Lewis Hamilton, the guy who,
fuck it always wins. Um,
so I can't be a markable Aila. I like
Mark Marcus. I'm not saying I'm not a fan,
but it's just, I can't be like
some bandwagon guy. So the CEO.
So it was a guy watched last year
and I was just like, I like this guy.
He's always, you know, he's
always up there, you know,
on the podium or whatever.
He's calming.
I liked him and I liked a Johan Zarko.
I just liked his bike and he was always
up there and he seemed like he didn't
have as good a bike is other people that
he was somehow fucking with those guys.
So I watched the first.
MMM.
I watched the first race and uh,
I had missed all the qualifying nic.
Johan Zarko has pulpit
position. I was like, Holy Shit.
Last year his whole story was like,
this guy is like right there,
but shit just kept happening.
Um,
and he didn't quite get over the Hump
and areas. The first race of the year,
the guys got the pole position. So
I watched the race. And by the way,
if you think this is a big time
commitment, it's like 22, 23 fucking lap.
She can watch the whole race
in 40 minutes. There's no
pit stops. And by the way,
it's people racing on motorcycles
going over 200 miles an hour.
Now they're going to say kilometers.
So it's simple math.
Every 80 kilometers is 50 miles an hour.
Okay?
So a lot of times they go in
like you know, 240 kilometers.
That means they're going to buy 150 miles
an hour. And then on the straightaways,
when they go by,
all the fans to start finish line,
they will get up over 300 320
when they get to 320 they go,
they're going 200 fucking miles an hour
on a motorcycle and there's someone
right on their ass and they have a big
fucking turn that they have to slow
down for. And the big fucking move,
who has the balls to break last usually
comes out of the turn the fastest.
However, if you go with, if
you brake too fucking late,
you might go to widen the guy who will
cut into neath IA or you could go flying
off your bike and die. All right. Now,
if that's not enough excitement
for you that I, I don't know.
I don't want to tell you.
So anyway,
so I'm watching this race and hand Zarko
in the lead for the whole fucking race
and they keep talking about his front
tire cause he's averaging like, I don't,
I don't know what they're, his average
was like one 50, 150 kilometers.
Uh, which would be what, oh, Jesus built.
That's like a little over a hundred
miles an hour is what he was average.
And that's, you know, with all the turns
slowing down and all that shit, right? Um,
I'm sitting there watching this
fucking guy and I'm like, Holy Shit.
Is this guy going to go wire to wire
and winning and they keep talking.
This was something, I need
people into this, this, uh,
into racing to explain to me.
They just kept talking about yo hands
Arccos front tire and saying it's
eventually it's going to wear down and
he's going to have a fucking problem.
And before it happened to him and
happened to Valentino Rossi and all of a
sudden, like he was in second place and
all of a sudden on one lap he got, um,
he got passed by like two people. But
then it's like he made this adjustment,
which is why he's evidently the
one of the greats of all time.
And he was able to come back and still
make the podium and come in third place.
But when it happened to Zarko,
he just,
he got passed by two people
at the same fucking time.
You went from first place the whole race
down to not even be in on the fucking
podium.
And then he ended up finishing eighth.
And why doesn't he have the same
fucking tires as the other guys?
How come,
how come his tires are wearing down
faster than other people?
What the fuck does this Zarko guy
have to do to get the best shit?
I know, I'm probably fucking this up.
So anyways, uh, to vizios so right.
He was like in ninth
place starting the race.
So I was kind of keeping an eye on him,
you know,
like what's his face when I was
watching the Formula One when uh,
Valtteri Botox started way in the back
because of the gear shift penalty, uh,
changing out the gearbox fucking
a penalty gear shift penalty,
the gearbox penalty and um,
I just watched him slowly move his way
up through the field and then the last
two laps of the race.
Okay. He's in first place.
Mark Mark has is in second
place and last year.
This is like the Brady
fucking Peyton manning.
This is Starbuck for stabler Elway
verse Montana. This is just like,
okay,
this is Jordan verse Dominic Week Wilkins.
Doug can contact one of the
great chaebol a first Russell,
whatever the fuck you want to call it.
And these guys were fucking writing
like maniacs for the last two laps.
Marquez is right on divisio sows ass and
he just knew it wasn't easy going gonna
pass them.
It's when is he going to pass him because
he did this all fucking last year.
It drove me nuts,
which is why I became a Davinci also fan.
You got to gotta to root for the underdog,
right.
So there's like fucking two or
three corners left and they're like,
I don't think Marquez is close enough.
And all of a sudden he braked later than
Divisio so name was right on his ass
and the next fucking corner he fucking
goes underneath divisio so and passed
them. And I didn't even
realize I was that into it.
I was in the living room and
I would just went like, Nah,
my wife comes running into,
what's the matter?
She thought there was something
wrong with that kid. So he does,
he goes dives underneath the visio.
So at this point,
you know that go in like 90 fucking
miles an hour in a turn with their knee,
like a like an eighth of an
inch off the fucking ground.
And he ducks underneath them.
But he was going so fast,
he went a little wide and then divisio
so went underneath him and then it was
just a fucking flat out race on
a straightaway, just pinning it
all the way to the fucking finish line.
Individ CEO so wins it. It was just an,
it's everything that's missing in Formula
One as far as like, I love Formula One,
I'm going to continue to watch it,
but I just fucking hate lawyers.
It's just a race to the first corner and
whoever's in the first corner is going
to be driving and clean air
and everything. Everybody
is so equally matched.
No one's going to be able to pass them
and then you just have to wait for
someone to fuck up in the
pits. Like that's the exciting
passing. It's just like,
can this guy get out of the pits before
that second place guy comes around again?
Um, I dunno just, but if you're,
if you're missing passing and Formula One,
uh,
I would suggest jumping sports. You can
watch them both. I mean, it's, they,
it's not that much that you're committing
to 40 races a year on a 365 days.
I mean, he can tape them, you can watch
them whenever you want to. So, uh,
I am 100% sold on this fucking sport
and I'm actually going to be taking a
vacation coming up when I'm celebrating
my 50th birthday and I just realized I'm
going to be in the vicinity of a that
race in Spain and I'm trying to talk my
wife into going with me. That's my, uh,
and I'll just be like,
come on honey.
It's my 50th birthday and
she's such a sweetheart.
I think she's going to do it by the way,
a honorary mentioned to a cow crutch
low coming in fourth place and run a
writing a great race and having one of
the great fucking names of all time,
cal crutch Lowe is such a fucking
cool name. It doesn't even sound like,
it sounds like an alias.
Like if I was a cop,
I wouldn't believe him if cuts
him under age drinking. All right,
give me your names. What's your
name? Uh, cal crutch low. Alright,
get up against the wall. He
going downtown. I just got
it. God, it's my real name.
Um, anyways, all I gotta do a little
read here. I got to do a little re,
I get a little read here. Uh, and
then get on with my fucking day,
cause I got another show. I'm coming
up where I'm going to be playing drums.
I've got to make sure I tightened down
the fucking bass drum beater before I
play.
I'm doing a Dean del Rey's is,
is uh, what was it, 52nd birthday. And uh,
I played drums on his 50th birthday.
It's great. He has a whole standup show.
And then after that he came out for
his 50th birthday with a live band.
He sang the entire AC DC
highway to hell album.
So for his 52nd, he's going
to be singing the, uh,
the entire, uh, power age album.
So I'm playing a couple
of songs off of that,
so I gotta make sure
I have that shit down.
And I'm also gonna make sure that the bass
drum beater is fucking tightened down.
Um, but whatever. And once again,
trying to learn those songs
that I've been learning I,
and really be able to play him a
whole new, I already had a love,
uh, Phil Rudd, but Jesus Christ,
I mean, he's just, he just,
it's perfect what that
guy's plays is perfect. Uh,
but there's gonna be a bunch of,
you know, big musicians there,
cause dean came up in the, in
that world, the music world,
so he knows all of these guys.
Um,
I think there's a flyer somewhere
out there, I believe. I think I,
but actually I believe it's already
fucking sold out. But, um, that's my day.
I'm going to go fucking play drums.
Huh?
I don't know why all you
guys don't become comedians.
You get to be a fucking kid
for the rest of your life. Um,
actually it's not that easy.
After 20 years of
sitting there going like,
did I make the biggest mistake of my life?
Then all of a sudden the clouds part,
you know,
unless you have a look,
unless you have a look and then he gets
scooped up early and they chew you up,
spit you out. All right. Oh
look who see about [inaudible]
the,
yeah, I got nothing to fucking say.
Do, do, do, do me on these be on DCF.
Few balls feel like they're rubbing on,
hey,
put on a pair up against you
and that they'll feel real good.
You won't give up.
Fuck cause me undies has the best
underwear and they'll feel nice up against
your pubic hair. Oh yeah. Alright. Right.
Is everybody you've heard me talk about
me undies and you know what that I am a
big believer in their products.
They're the perfect
balance of comfortable fit.
Every month they have new and exciting
prints and they arrive at your door in a
fun bag. Talk about why me
undies, other best underwear.
Uh, I liked that my balls
don't fall out of, you know,
if that's been a problem with like
tidy whities, you know what I mean?
They've got the little pee hole there
and a, just the way it's situated,
if you know, if your balls are
fucking, you know, I dunno,
just sorta really relaxed that day. All
of a sudden, yeah, you got an issue.
You know what I mean?
Oh,
does that work me undies core copy
running, wired, billable. Why are they,
why do they have the title
me on these uses Lens Zig,
Lenzing Lenzing.
That sounds like a metal band that never
made it. Do you remember that band?
Lenzing they did a couple of good songs.
Lenzing micro modal,
modal and their underwear.
It's sustainably sourced.
Naturally thought fire,
but that starts with beechwood trees
and ends with the most amazing fabric
you've ever experienced.
I have to find a a making
of Lenzing micro modal,
modal. How do you start with trees and
then end up with something that can be up
against your body.
You know,
even if they polished it down like I
don't think I would want to have like
guitar grade wood up against my nuts,
but for several,
I don't know how they do it anyways. The
results have been downright dreamy man.
Me undies has a great offer
for my listeners for any
first time purchasers when
you purchase any me undies,
you get 20% off and free shipping.
Me undies is so Shilla.
You'll love their underwear.
They offer a 100% satisfaction guarantee.
If you don't fucking love your first pair,
you get a full refund.
This is a no brainer.
Get 20% off a pair of the most comfortable
undies you will ever put on to get
your 20% off your first pair.
Free Shipping.
100% satisfaction guarantee.
Go to [inaudible] dot com slash bird.
That's me undies, m e U, N D. I e. S m, e,
u, n d. I e. S me on
dies.com/bar.
I slowed that down cause I realized,
you know people have brains like mine.
That would have been too fast.
How do you spell it?
Helix. Everybody. How Ix? Uh,
there's nobody on the planet
like you know, you're special.
So why would you buy a mattress
built for everyone else? Well,
what about your doppelganger?
Maybe you could go fucking have a sleep
over at his house working with the
world's leading sleep experts.
There's sleep experts. Can you get laid
talking about what do you do? Pick boy.
Uh, I'm a sleep expert.
Oh, I love sleeping. Well,
why don't you come over here to sleep
on this Dick. Sorry. He looks sleepy.
Developed a mattress, the elk, Jesus.
What today's sensitive people is. He is,
he was he just advocating drugging people.
MMM.
He looks sleep.
Developed a mattress that customized
that's customized to your specific height,
weight and sleep preferences so you can
have the best sleep of your life and an
unbelievable price. Here's
how it works. Go to helix,
sleep.com fill out their two minutes
sleep quiz and they'll design your custom
mattress. What do you dream about? Um,
they even customize each side for your,
for you and your partner in 2018 he
looks sleep has taken customized sleep to
the next level with
the Helix helux pillow.
The all new pillows are fully adjustable
so you can achieve perfect comfort.
How they adjustables La,
a little motor in there.
Would that be up against your head?
How would that be comfortable regardless
of sleep position of body type,
Heloc sleep has thousands
of five star reviews.
Omni one star reviews do you have,
you just can't talk about the good times.
Plus you get a hundred nights
to try them up. Go to helix,
sleep.com/bar right now and you get up
to $125 towards your mattress order.
That's healing. sleep.com/bar
for up to $125 off your mattress.
Order Hallux.
sleep.com/ [inaudible] spelled spelled h.
E. L. I. X. Was there a band called that
Hellickson Band said Helix.
Maybe that's why I always fucked that up.
Were they the guys who were like,
give me an r o c k and what you got
rock and what are we going to do?
Rock you.
It was like if cheerleaders
made a heavy metal song.
Okay.
That's the spirit rebel
against your parents are right.
My Internet's not working. All right,
that is the podcast. Have a great weekend.
You fucking cunts. I'm going to
be at the Brady that Todd radioed.
He said best the Brady Theater in Tulsa,
Oklahoma with let there be talks.
Dean del Rey and then we're going down
to San Antonio for two shows and I for
the life of me,
couldn't figure out why it was like 500
fucking bucks a night for a hotel in San
Antonio.
I'm like,
what do they have some new hipster area
or something and they may can cupcakes
and riding bicycles. Why is
everything so expensive? Well,
it turns out that the night I'm there,
so it's the final four weekend,
so I bet a lot of you are thinking like,
oh,
bill came in town to go to those games
and I had no idea that games were there
and I'm just paying five times what I
normally would have paid for 'em for a
hotel room. You know, I just
realized whatever happened to five,
four club Faffel Club,
motherfucker
did.
They dumped me in a what?
I am so sick of being,
I feel like I'm that podcast that like
advertisers go to right before they meet
their soulmate podcast.
You know what I mean?
You know that chick who's always the
fucking bridesmaid, never a bride.
That's what I'm starting to feel.
I just don't feel that people
understand what the fuck it is.
It just cause I joked doesn't mean people
take it seriously in the Goddamn copy
and make some listen to it
rather than fast forward to it.
It's so fucking simple. Why can't you
Madison Avenue Kuntz figured that out
or maybe they're going to be
advertising my podcast next week. Don't,
and I probably should have checked with
my, my producer before I sit there.
But you know what he did all right.
That's okay.
Here's a little bit of music and then uh,
I don't know.
I guess we'll fucking, we'll play in some
half hour. Greatest Sense. You know what?
I'm actually, I'm going to tell my guy
to fucking put a slayer south. They have
bad odor, right? Go fuck
yourselves. I'll see on Monday.
False.
Have you guys seen this youtube video?
My name is John Dacre.
You got to watch this thing.
I apologize cause it's going to be in
your fucking head for the rest of time.
He's singing, he's singing a moray
and he can't remember how to say
[inaudible]
I can't stop watching. This
guy is guy. I swear to God,
I think it's his first TV Gig.
Somebody was sick,
I think they said at the beginning. So
this guy fills in and if you look at him,
he's literally having an
outer body experience.
So it's so funny to me
because I can relate to this
person because at first time
I did stand up,
I felt like I was watching myself.
I've fucked everything up and this guy,
just the way he says his name,
it's almost the just,
he says like,
my name is John Dacre.
Yeah,
yeah.
It's like,
it's like he was outside.
I think that might be my favorite part of
the video is the when this fucking guy,
just the way he says his own name,
he didn't say, my name is John Dacre.
He goes,
my name's John Decker.
I did it right the first time and I just
fucked it up. And you got to hear this.
Yeah, this fucking guy. He says
he's singing all these Jesus songs.
Hang on,
hang on.
Okay.
My name is John Baker.
That's the funniest shit ever.
My name's John Taker.
It's like he's watching his life,
like he already died
and then he came back and he just got to,
okay.
Like he first time you ever realize
my name. My name is John [inaudible].
Yeah,
that's my fucking name.
And this is my life and I'm on TV
and I'm going to sing this song.
This is what I did with my life.
You look at the Gut fucking poor bastard.
Yeah.
Oh my God. Listen to him sing. Hallelujah.
[inaudible]
okay.
Ugh. Damn. But for the grace of God,
this fucking guy would be the most
interesting Andrew view ever. Just like,
yeah,
he's one of the most fascinating
people I've ever seen. Like what?
What is going on in between
those fucking ears right now?
Think if they could eat,
you could make a show about his fucking
thoughts in all these fucking movies out
. It's, yeah. You know
they show the movie,
but it's done in reverse and then they
try to fucking flip you out. Nothing.
Nothing pink Floyd could ever fucking
right can match what's going on in this
guy's head. Highly
recommended. All right. Yeah.
[inaudible]
what's going on?
And is this the Monday morning
podcast for Monday, March 29th,
2010 so one or two degrees out here.
Little Sue Julius Holly. How are Ya?
How's it going? I know I've been
getting a ton of emails do it.
It's still not up on iTunes. I don't
know what's going on. All right.
All I know is I just keep
recording these fucking things.
Having faith that we'll finally
get these fucking things up there.
I know we're going to,
and I'm going to go out on a limb
and say this is definitely the week
everything's going to be up there,
but until then I'm going to whore
myself out and tell you that the Monday
morning podcast starring me,
myself,
and I is only a exclusively
on billboard.com that's
the only place she can get
it. See what I did like a drug dealer.
I gave you a couple of free samples.
Actually I didn't.
I gave you two and a half fucking years
of free samples and then I fucking
pulled it.
Are you guys are all fiend and Ford?
I'm going to get you to
in my fucking website,
right.
I'll get a bunch of hits on my website,
then I'll start selling advertising for
like tampons or something and I'll make
a fortune. Get a midget and a hooker. Hang
on. I have to sneeze. Where's The sun?
Where's this on? Come on. Give me some
sun. There it is. There it is. Nothing.
I hate that. When you feel it. It's
like fucking blue balls for you knows.
I thought it was gonna fucking
sneezer nothing. All right.
Anyways, it's Monday, March 29th. Um,
I have not watched one 2nd of
March madness and is always,
it's the best fucking sporting event of
the year. And I don't know what happened.
I was over in April and, uh,
I was over in Europe, so, uh,
you know, I wasn't there in the
beginning, so I missed the whole thing.
I watched Kentucky lose
yesterday and I got to Mit.
I can't really look at John Calipari the
way I used to have to, what's his face?
Verbally, bitch slapped him. Um,
that angry white haired guy from Indiana
who then went to Texas and now he just
talks about games.
The fuck's his name.
Actually went to a game when I was
out there when it was still out. Damn.
What the fuck is his name?
I keep thinking white to his hair.
Jesus Christ. He's one of the great
coaches of all time. Come on bill.
You've been gone to lumosity.com focus.
Let it go.
Just don't care about it. I
don't give a fuck. No, I care.
My brain can tell. I care.
So it's just hiding it. Just
mocking me. Come on work.
Bobby Knight. There we go. Add to think
of him throwing the chair. Uh, yeah,
he called GTV key actually called John
Calipari out on some kind of decent,
he said,
you know,
every fucking program that this guy
has been a part of has had some sort of
problem with the NCAA and then
he jets out of town, you know,
continuing to build his resume
and he really trashed him. Now,
I'm not saying what he said was right,
but Calipari Ali came back with, was a,
a a respect globby night.
I think he's a great coach.
And he didn't that you didn't
address anything. You know,
somebody told me I killed a hooker
and they were a friend of mine and I
respected them. I would address the
killing of the hooker at some point. Uh,
in my innocence of it.
Yeah.
Before I, you know, after, you know,
after I said how much I respected the guy.
Right.
You know,
I went to a game one time out there in
Indiana with Bobby Knight was still there
and he was, you know, Indiana
started to lose. It was a year.
Michigan State won the championship.
I think it was the year 2000.
I already 10 years ago.
And I went to this fucking game and I
remember about a student ticket and, uh,
you know, showed up. At that
point I was well into my thirties.
And the guy's looking at
me like, really? You know,
what do you want the fucking 12 year plan?
That's when he got to come with the
fucking Luther vibe from a 48 hour.
I've been busy number.
That's shit.
When he pulls up to the toll booth of
the parking garage thing and the guy's
like this tickets like four
years old. Yeah, I been busy.
That was a vibe. Me, I just gave the
guy that's like, come on man, come on.
Really it's me.
So he let me in and I went in there and
I remember watching Bobby Knight and it
was a fucking great arena and
there he was, the legend, right?
I was up in the nosebleeds,
but uh,
Indiana started losing and he started,
he walked out on the court and was
yelling at the point guard bringing it up.
The court like his, his whole fucking
head was just, you know, with,
just with every,
you fucking mother fucking like is like a,
like a rooster with Tourette's. Right.
Just, just fucking unbelievable.
And I remember I got so Goddamn
mad watching him do that.
I was just like,
I was,
I wanted that kid just to take the ball
and just fire it right into his fucking
screaming face.
I have a son and he allows himself
to get fucking yelled at like that.
You know what I mean?
You fucking retard control your
goddamn emotions. All right?
You want to fucking blow up a little bit,
Blah.
But this guy had completely lost his shit.
Yeah.
Yeah. Do you ever see Marvin
Hagler when he fought Tommy Hearns,
remember when he was punching him in the
head and Tommy's fucking head would go
back in his Jerry curl, all the
shit from it would fly out. Instead,
he was doing that with his head to
himself, except instead of going back,
he was going forward every time he was
making a point to this kid. He's like,
Ben Kingsley and sexy beast make me
look like a right cunt hair dark.
You're fucking learn to fucking,
ah, he's leading with this head.
Fucking right. Cross white to is
fuck, I fucking hate people like that.
Remind me of one of my relatives. Um,
well, I just really revisited that anger,
didn't I? Um, so anyways,
I was actually going to do this
podcast last night at, uh, at,
at 12 midnight now that I've been over
to Europe and I found out how many people
listen to my podcast over there. You
know, I'm starting to have a little, uh,
you know, responsibility for
those people. Like, you know,
I now know that England and Ireland
are seven hours ahead of me.
So if I did it at midnight Monday
nights, if I posted it then, I mean,
Sunday nights, you know, they're rolling
into work couple hours later, you know,
and I know what you thinking down
there in Australia. Ooh, what about us?
We're fucking 14 hours ahead.
Go fuck yourselves. All right,
the fuck do you want me to do it
on Thursdays every week? You know,
why don't you be happy?
Why don't you guys just focus on the
fact that you guys don't get respect for
living on the largest
island in the fucking world.
You know, Disney should've made a
cartoon about you guys, not Madagascar.
Huh?
What was that about?
So sick of those fucking cartoons about
animals that know about global warming.
And then they teach human beings a lesson.
You know,
do you realize that like 98%, and I
just grabbed that stat right out of ass,
reach right in and pulled it out.
98% of fucking animals,
including the goddamn insects. There's an
insect, an animal. I know what a human,
um,
98% of those motherfuckers are murderers
every day,
every fucking day.
When they want to go out and get something
to eat, they have to commit a murder.
You know, they got to set a trap.
They got an ambush. Should ever do it.
Fucking face to face. You ever
seen a fucking animal, you know,
be a gentlemen,
come up and slap another fucking beast
with his glove and say, I challenge you.
I challenge you to a meal off.
I want to eat,
you know, all pieces of shit.
Fucking animals. What about
me? I don't kill anybody.
I go and eat an animal that's already
been murdered. I am accomplice to murder.
That's what the fuck I am. Um,
I did I get on that subject?
What was I talking about? It's
talking about Bobby Knight. Oh,
some of those stupid fucking animal
movies at Disney's always make and try to
make me cry, you know, and say,
have some polar bears slide
on his belly into a coke can.
The same fucking thing that would
just be eating me alive. Um,
if you only get mauled by an animal,
if you had to get eaten by an animal,
which one would you pick?
I picked the biggest fucker ever.
I want that shit to be over.
Cause I remember when that gay dude
with the evil Knievel, a Onesy,
the Joan Jett fucking Leotard.
Remember those two guys out there sick,
free and roid. Roid sick free and Roy,
Siegfried and Roy,
remember those two twinkle toes out there,
dance around with all those fucking,
you know, whatever they had. They,
they're cats. They were doing
cats. The musical for real.
Whenever you thrill cats,
I think that'd be spectacular.
We just skip around and
I'll bleach my hair.
And then you put shoe
fallish in yours. Yeah. Well,
Robert's bowls.
I'm actually,
that's bullshit because the musical
cats came out after fucking, uh, the,
the, the fucking, those
two guys, gay evil Knievel.
And uh, and gay. Uh, who's the other one?
What did he look like? A, who's the
other guy at night at the Roxbury,
not will Pharrel. Ah, Jesus.
My is just shot Catan.
That's what it looks like.
If they ever,
if they ever make the movie
that I would cast a Catan.
Chris Catan is the one who gets his
neck chopped and then I would have to go
with the guy who played
Bo Duke and the rob and I.
He's too fucking old at this point. Who's
got hair like that? God knows I don't,
even if you fucking bleached it, I got
enough left. Hang on a second. Who the
fuck would I pick?
Yeah,
whatever. There's your project
for the week. But anyways,
my point is that when he grabbed
the, the, the gay Chris Catan, dude,
it was just over. It wasn't like, Oh
God, I'm getting eaten by an island.
An island, a fucking lie.
Jesus. It wasn't that.
It was just scrapped his
fucking throat and that was it.
He went chomp and that was it. That
was it. Just fucking off. I know,
Bill, we saw it. We saw
it on fucking Hollywood.
Aina aided a bitch or whatever
the fuck that, that's stupid.
He Hollywood bowl shows he Hollywood
fucking stories about celebrities and
addition all this dirt about them.
Did you ever notice that none of
their close friends are on it?
It's because it's all bullshit.
You know
they do like the willy aim story
and they have like his fucking made
talk and all sorts of shit about them.
There's grant. Good Eve say anything? No.
Does the kid who played Nicholas Bradford,
does he say some shit now with none of
them say anything? It's always like,
you know some fucking PA.
I don't know what the fuck I'm talking.
I was talking about animals.
Let's rewind this for a second.
Yeah, those stupid fucking call.
If you've got to get killed by an
animal. That's what I'm saying. I want,
I want to get fucking killed by
something like that. A big cat or a bear.
You know there's something about an
alligator though. I just, I don't like it.
I don't like that they have fucking
them. They're mean about it. You know,
they just did. They grab your leg and
then they do that fucking barrel roll.
You know, it's like, can't you just
fucking shot my leg off? Can you just,
just nice clean Ginsu it and you
know it a major writer there.
I'll fucking bleed out
in like five seconds.
Do you really got to Joe
Theismann me to the 10th power.
You guys ever seen that clip?
Non Sports fans.
If you want to see something that'll
just make you lose your lunch for all you
broads out there trying
to lose some weight.
If you just had a piece of cake right now,
go on youtube and look up Joe Theismann
breaks leg or Joe Theismann uh,
who landed on him. Lawrence Taylor.
Remember that shit? It's, it's a,
it's a two foot one break compound
fracture I believe is what,
what is what is called the
Tabula and the fibula. Uh,
yeah, I think that's
what it is. Look at me.
Follow fucking pulling another
thing out of my age. Um,
alright, so this is the deal. It's
Monday morning out here in Los Angeles.
She probably wondering, hey bill,
you know what? What does that,
what does a struggling actor,
moderately successful comedian
do on a Monday morning? Well,
I'll tell you right now.
I had a fucking audition and I prepared
my little actor hard out for it.
And uh, it was one of the roles I've
always wanted to play. All right. Um,
there's a few scenes that I want
that I want to do as an actor.
A lot of actors want to win an Oscar.
Of course I
do. But who's kidding, Hill.
You know one of my jeans,
Staple Horn said somebody's
name. I don't know. Fuck,
that is a triple horn. I don't know
what the fuck I'm trying to say here.
Look who's getting to it will
be 42 years old in June. Okay.
If I can just stand near somebody who won
a fucking Oscar, I'm going to be happy.
All right. So anyways, um, and you know
what I'm doing? I'm adjusting my dream.
Okay.
Rather than going on Oprah now and
having her ask me how I became so fucking
brilliant. Now all I want to
do, I want to have that scene.
I want to play a snitch.
That's what I want to do and I want to
have somebody chased me down a fucking
alley.
I don't give a fuck if it's the cops
are the guys I snitched on and I want to
come to the end of the alley.
I want that chain link fence.
You know where you grab it and you're
trying to climb up it and you think you're
going to make it and then they grab
you by your cheap leather coat.
They pull you off it and kick
the shit out of you. I want that.
I want to do the interrogation scene.
You know when I'm sitting there,
then they're doing the good cop,
bad cop. I've already been the cop.
I did that on Chappelle show.
I want to be the guy getting interrogated.
And then the last thing is I want to get
my fucking head blown off in a movie.
So today and I have the perfect head,
my big fucking kitchen TV set head,
my Sean Penn forehead. I mean this,
it's just begging to be fucking blown
off in a movie. I'm dying for that scene.
Right? And I had an audition
today to, uh, to play.
A Gal gets fucking shot in the
head. In the end, I was site,
I was feeling good. I worked the
whole fucking thing out, right?
So I go down to the audition and I show
up on me at the address and I'm looking
at somebody's house like, what the
fuck? This is somebody goddamn house.
This doesn't seem right.
So recheck the address.
And then I saw a couple of people
walking in holding this sides. Um,
so I was like, all right, fuck it. Not
Sides for those unit in the business,
they didn't walk in with like
mashed potatoes and stuffing.
It's fucking sides are basically
the part of the script,
the couple of scenes that they give you.
Um,
so I go walking in there and I walk in
and all I see is two Asian guys in suits.
And I'm like, all right, this is weird.
Because basically what happens when you,
when you audition for a role,
they kind of know what they want.
Every once in awhile they do that,
all ethnicities.
But basically I walk in there and there's
a bunch of howdy duty looking guys.
You know, Donnie most is in there
fucking resent and me, you know,
cause my red hair hasn't
turned yellow yet.
No, it's not all red heads, but you know,
it's a bunch of fucking white dudes
about my age, you know. And um,
this time I walk in,
it's two Asian dudes,
one with the shaved head and one
with fucking Chow, young fat hair,
and they're both sitting there.
And I'm like, what the fuck?
I must be coming in at the tail end of,
we're trying to find the Asian dude.
And uh, I walk in and I sign in and it
was right as I sign in to say I'm there,
the casting person came and I was like,
oh my God.
I tried to call and I was like,
oh fuck.
I tried to call, try to email
you. Basically they, they,
I dunno. I Dunno if they cast it, they
gave it to somebody famous or what,
but they basically tried to call me to say
that, uh, they were rewriting the role.
I love when somebody says that I
tried to call really what happened. I,
I dunno, I, I dialed it, but I
couldn't pick up the, I tried,
I couldn't
just be honest.
It was a late night fucking decision,
you know, and I had the one,
I was one of the first guys coming out
of the chute. It's no big deal. Whatever.
I'm already showered,
looking good today.
It was still would've been
sleeping like a bump. So, uh, yeah,
my day started a little fucked up. What
are you going to do? Whatever, whatever,
whatever. I'm 16, 17
minutes into this podcast,
they got a little bowl of grapes here.
Um,
and people let me tell you something.
I am severely, severely off the wagon.
All right. I stumbled
in last night and, uh,
all I had was two beers.
I don't know what the fuck happened.
I was like stumbling and I,
you know, got out of my car,
which I probably shouldn't
have been driving. I two
beers in an hour and a half.
So, I mean, I think I'm not drunk, right?
Your body gets rid of a one drink an hour.
Isn't that what it is?
All I know is I have this fucking little
zip up, right? My little fucking, uh,
you know, I don't know what
it is. It's like a fun,
I think it has the English flag
on it. It's white. It's weird.
It looks like really American
because it's red, white and blue.
It's a fucking cool look and zip up.
It makes me look maybe two and a half
years younger than I am and I'm vain,
so I wear it.
So I stumble out of my car and I brush
up against the hinge of the garage and I
was like, fuck. And I look down and I have
this Greece, at least it was brand new,
so it was kind of green
looking and I ruined it.
And I just sat there and I remembered
what this recovered alcoholic told me when
I wasn't drinking. I was like,
Yeah Dude, I'm done with drinking.
And he looked at me and he said, yeah
man. He goes, nothing good comes from it.
And I was like, once again, this
guy is right when you're younger,
good stuff comes from it. You get laid,
you get charged with date rape later,
but you know, in the moment it's
good. Um, no, you know what I mean?
Loosens people up.
You don't know how to talk to a luck.
Be a lady two night.
Let me get you drunk and less uptight.
Gonna stick my finger in
your fucking who has sweetie,
whether you want it or
not. Now doing it. I don't,
I'm not advocating rape here. I just felt
like singing. So let me have a grape.
Maybe that'll take me down here.
Oh. Oh God. Isn't that delicious?
It was the last time you
bought some grapes and actually
finished. Um, you know,
I'm trying to, cause I, when
I came back from Europe,
I threw out a hellacious amount of food.
I want you to think a starving kid ways.
Because when I walked out, I felt like I
had like six of them in my garbage bag.
That's how much food I threw out.
Some of them were jars,
you know, wasn't all food. Some of
it was the containers, but you know,
a lot of it's made out of cardboard at
this point. I threw out a lot of food.
That's what I'm trying to tell
you. So I'm really, I'm try,
I bought some food this week and
I'm trying to eat all of it up.
I'm trying to be a less wasteful American.
Oh,
speaking of that shit.
The fuck did I look up?
I was on youtube the other day and they
had these German mother fuckers and they
would, they would, they were trying
out the new, um, um, dodge challenger.
The fucking Xjs sets a Jaguar,
whatever the fuck you call it, the,
the Hemi one versus the
Shelby Mustang versus, um,
that dodge viper and their whole thing
was they just kept relating the cars to
eating fast food and a big cheeseburger.
They will basically saying,
these are American cars.
Americans are fat fucks. And, uh,
I gotta admit, man, we earned it. We
did earn it, but you know, we don't do,
we don't test out a Porsche and Audi
in a BMW with some sort of Nazi theme
underneath it. You know, I'm fucking
really getting tired of this man.
Everybody's taken shots at the good
old USA. So you know you got to do,
I've got a new segment called
let's get smart America.
I wish she had some sort of production
on this where I could just have a fucking
silly ass song.
What are you going to do this week as
it a fucking American to make yourself a
little less fat?
A little less dumb,
a little less something else.
Cause the magic number's three.
Say I'm too fucking stupid to
come up with three examples.
What are you going to do? I got to tell
you, these motherfuckers over in England,
man,
are not in good shape and they weren't
in good shape and fucking in Scotland
either. Ireland, they
were all right. You know,
it's like they're not fat,
but they just like,
they look like at a shake.
Seventh graders,
like there's not a lot of weightlifting
over there. Like I just saw arms.
You don't like straight arms like Dilbert.
I'm not saying they're all like that,
so fucking don't get your blood up over
there. Right. You know what I'm saying?
Put it this way. My girlfriend
saw somebody over in, um, in,
uh,
we were fucked with,
I think we were in Scotland and she saw
somebody and this kid looked like he was
in his early twenties, his
face. But his body was just,
she just looked at me and she just goes,
his body is unacceptable.
And it wasn't even that he was
fucking ridiculously out of shape.
It's just that not only those
fucking guys over there mushy,
they were the tightest fucking shirts
ever. I'm not saying I'm in shape.
I got a nice little fucking poach going
right now that I need to try to work
down.
But I have the decency,
the common fucking decency for my
fellow man to wear a button down.
You know,
give yourself a little space,
let it hang off your man tits a little
bit so we don't have to see, you know,
these fucking guys over in Europe,
it's like,
they want you to know exactly how
many pounds overweight they were.
It was disgusting.
You know,
and appreciate a little courtesy out of
my fellow man. That's all I'm saying.
Okay. You got, you've gotta be
honest with yourself. All right.
What kind of shape? My mind wife
shape am I and t shirts shape?
Am I in fucking buttoned down shape?
Do I need to put on a Hoodie?
You know, sport coach
shape. Remember that Shit.
I used to have a regular job. Why am
I walking around? I think I'm excited.
This is one of the exciting
moments of the podcast for me.
Look at me pacing back and forth as if
I'm fucking coming up with some brilliant
shit here.
I remember when I had a regular job,
he used to work in a warehouse
unloading trucks. You know,
it's not curing cancer,
but it served a purpose and a,
I remember once a year they would have,
they'd have the company cookout and all
these fucking suits that you thought
were in shape do. They would show up
with their fucking tee shirts on. Wow.
Wow.
You know,
I'm talking like a fucking big slice of
cake just hanging off each side of him.
I remember it made me feel
good too because they will
make them more money than
me,
you know?
You know when you do that,
you just fucking good your
wedding in that category.
So I'm glad that you're losing in
this one. Did that go anywhere?
Have another grape? God Damn
it. These things are tart. So
here we go. I'm trying to become
a better speller everybody.
And uh, I'm sick of being a
fucking moron in that category.
So I figured I'd give you a
spelling test this week. All right?
You don't have to play along.
You know what am I going to do that I
can keep fucking rambling for another 40
minutes. She can tell at this point. I
don't have shit to talk about this week.
I just emptied my brain on Thursday.
It takes a week for it to fill up.
It's like it just jerked off
and you want another load?
I don't have one inmate got a
fucking empty chamber this week.
All right, you guys sitting at your
desks, this would be even better. This.
And you know what's great about this?
If I actually add this to the podcast
where I teach it fucking 10 words every
week, okay? We all learn and
together this is the great thing.
Cause if you're listening to a guy
at work, you shouldn't be doing that.
You know it. And I know it looked
down in shame right now at your desk.
Now don't fuck that.
He shouldn't have any shame.
Did you dream about your job then?
There's no fucking shame fucking off. Um,
the great part about this part of the
podcast is you're actually going to start
writing and people going to
be thinking, Oh wow, okay.
Sandy's over there taking notes
on something important, you know,
who fucks off and writes at the same
time. Um, all right, so here we go.
Here's 10 words that I think,
uh,
I don't think anything about them.
These are just words I fucking found
that I could, I couldn't spell.
Catalysts is the first word.
What did this yelled at into the mic.
Catalysts is your first word. All right,
let's see how fucking dumb you are.
We need, we need to gauge
how fucking stupid you are
to have a jumping off point. All
right. Catalyst is your first word.
Um, can you use it in a sentence?
Uh, I don't think I can. Um,
this spelling test was the catalyst
to expose how fucking stupid I am.
Catalyst
is a fucked up one.
We all eat them cantaloupe.
Okay.
Hey, what'd you look at that
fucking cantaloupe? I, you know,
I just realized I could never do this.
I could never be a teacher. Chloroform,
okay.
Hey, you know what? If you
don't shut the fuck up,
I'm going to take a chloroform reg
and put it over your face there.
Chloroform.
God,
this is like designed to make you smarter
and it's really exposing how dumb I am
is a tough one. Uh, penitentiary.
Don't go to the penitentiary. You might
get fucked in the ass penitentiary.
Uh,
you know,
I love about this podcast is, even though
I have no idea whether this is the,
you know, I, there's no way
to hear feedback or anything.
I know this is bombing and I don't give
a shit. I don't know. You know what?
I don't even know how many I've done.
I'm going to fucking do all 10, one, two,
three. I did three, three c words
and I'm not, I would say contemplate.
It's too easy. Uh, let's
go with another one.
Yeah.
Was another one. Aesthetics. There's a
great one. Here's a great one. Aesthetics.
Use it in a sentence. Bill, come
on. You dummy. Jesus Christ.
Look at these aesthetics.
And you know, it's funny, I know
how to spell all these words now,
but I can't use them in a sentence.
Just really a fucking moron. All right,
let's go.
Infrastructure.
Yeah.
You know, I'm sick of this
infrastructure. It's really, uh,
it's really unnecessary infrastructure.
Now I can use that in a sentence.
The infrastructure of the
company was a exquisite,
Oh, Jesus Christ. Gee. Oh, G Gee,
what else we got? How many, how many words
is that? One, two, three. That's four.
Yeah,
there is a tough one. Succinct.
I think I did that last
succinct.
Um,
what somebody who stutters
brushes his teeth in a succinct,
can I just do five?
Can I bail on this?
Are you guys enjoying
how fucking horrific.
This is a pertinent,
okay,
what does that six, I'm going
to say that six pertinent. Um,
you know what?
This is pertinent information.
That's the only time anybody ever uses
that word is when they're describing
information.
Okay?
If I had an access to the pertinent,
pertinent information,
I wouldn't have to deal with this
infrastructure at this cantaloupe colored
company.
Pardon it? Fuck you. You don't even know
how to spell it. You can't smell it.
Spell it. You can't fucking be
laughing at me right now. All right.
Here's a fun [inaudible].
These ones are all the ones that have
psycho with the beginning of them.
Here's one. Uh, negotiate.
Yeah.
You know,
you guys want more money in your cubicles.
You're going to have to
negotiate. Oh, they go, she ate.
Was that eight?
Jeez,
I'm even getting bored with this. Uh, this
is a hell of a dilemma, Huh? Go ahead.
Spell that one dilemma.
I didn't realize this was going to bug
bomb and now I'm in a fucking dilemma.
Dilemma.
Yeah.
And when was the last one here?
A silhouette.
Yay. When I see your silhouette up against
the mood and makes me want to fucking
baggy silhouette. Ah,
all right. There you go.
There's your spelling tests for the week.
Do you have any desire to get better
at this shit, my superimposing.
That's what I do. I can spell all those
fucking words. Huh? Are you impressed?
You shouldn't be. Um, here's
another new segment bills,
embarrassing moments from
the previous week's podcast.
This is actually from two weeks ago. I
actually re listen to these when I, uh,
when I upload them,
it takes a moment for me to upload all
of these fucking things that no one can
hear unless you go to bill bird.com.
Um,
[inaudible] um,
and I listened to them and I listen,
I hear all the dumb shit that
I say and the stuff that I,
I miss pronounce like I was trying to
say exclamation point a couple of weeks
ago,
exclamation point as an exclaim.
And I actually said explanation point,
like it was explaining it
to me in a very excited way.
Um, Jesus Christ, this is
fucking awful. You know, this is,
you know what this is like, this is
like your second day back at the gym.
That's what this podcast feels like.
You know the first day like, fuck this,
you know,
when you go nuts and then the next day
you wake up and you're all sore and now
you just fucking drag and assets.
What this podcast is just
dragon fucking dragon.
My Freckle Das. I don't have
a freckle desk. By the way.
That would mean that I stunned
beds in the nude. Um, all right,
last week I was talking
about how our Avocados,
that whole bullshit where
they're, uh, they're too, oh wait,
that's for the wrong part of the podcast.
Where the fuck is that information?
No, Jesus Christ. Bill. You know
why? Why? Why do you even try? Oh,
I fucked up. I bet. I can
just tell you the gist of it.
The reason why Avocados costs more when
you go to get a Burrito was evidently
there was some damage done to the crop
a couple of years ago or some bullshit.
So there was a shortage of them.
Thus they were more expensive.
And as always,
the corporate cons pass the
expense onto the regular people.
And this is what happens.
Then they had more fucking avocado.
So it wasn't a fucking problem anymore,
but they were like, well wait a minute.
People are already paying more for
Avocados. Ain't never fucking complained.
So they just kept them at the same price.
So now you pay extra,
which means means when
it's time to change,
what it means is that
they're gonna fucking,
they're going to do that with every kind
of food now cause we're not bitching
about, um, our bacon. I've got a breakfast
sandwich and they said Bacon was extra.
So, you know what? That's my little
rebellion. Fuck you. All right.
I'm not paying extra for my Avocados,
for my guacamole.
You fucking cunts. You fuckin
corporate cons helping. Did you?
Goddamn ya'll gotta be all right.
Let me, let me, I'm, you know,
I'm going to wrap this up. You guys
are getting a mini podcast this week.
I'm not going to sit here and be treated
this way on my podcast and I sit here
fucking bomb and like this,
I got a reputation. Um,
last week I have saying I
didn't understand the difference
between Great Britain,
the United Kingdom is England,
a country is England in Scotland.
Two separate countries. Are they the
same fucking thing? It was all confusing.
So a this guy says, hey bill,
I'm from England, so I'll
answer your question mate.
Uh, England is a country, cause you said
on your podcast, England wasn't a country,
but is it you meant to write but it is,
what are you,
if you're questioning yourself sir,
what the fuck am I supposed to do?
Scotland is a country, Wales is
a country. I didn't know that.
I thought maybe Scotland was a country,
but I didn't think Wales was a country.
Ireland is a bit different because it's
split into two countries to spelled t oh
there's one of your smart
fucking Europeans there.
Everybody see that if we
learn how to spell America,
we can start making fun of them again.
We at least we can have a,
a basis to make fun of
them. Um, anyways, uh,
continuing Ireland is a bit different
because it's split into two countries.
Northern Ireland,
the Capitol is Belfast and the
Republic of Ireland Capitol is Dublin.
Both completely separate countries.
Countries,
spelled country apostrophe s yeah.
See this.
That's all they do over there.
They watch fucking soccer
and eat fish and chips.
They don't have fucking spell either.
United Kingdom.
And this is what the United Kingdom
is. It's a England, Scotland,
Wales and Northern Ireland. Great
Britain. Great Britain is England,
Scotland and Wales.
Reason being is Ireland is an island.
Hence why Northern Ireland
and the Republican Ireland
are just known as Ireland.
That doesn't make any sense.
England is in Ireland or whatever.
Fucking do the United Kingdom is an
island island. I don't understand that.
How come fucking,
uh,
Australia is not an eye is not considered
an island surrounded on all sides by
water.
You know what the fuck?
South America is an island at this
point with the Panama Canal, isn't it?
And why does it float away? Um, anyways.
Anyways, this podcast sucks. I'm sorry.
What? What the fuck do you want from me?
All right. I'm fucking Neil O'Donnell
this week. I've got nothing for you.
I started doing this spelling test and
all these fucking nerds came out of the
goddamn woodwork. This guy goes, Bill,
here's an interesting piece of trivia.
Facetious is the only word in the English
language that has every vowel in order.
A. E. I. O. U. Isn't that interesting? Is
that what I did with the spelling tests?
Maybe this is why I never learned how to
fucking spell cause that's the kind of
people that you attract. Here's an
interesting tidbit of information.
Do you know that on the fuck,
and they start talking about
some moon off of Saturn
that instead of fucking air,
it's that their atmosphere as methane gas.
And I got to sit and I guess sit there
and nod like wow, you know, and I'm like,
and he's sitting there thinking,
I'm nodding because I'm so fucking
interested and I'm really trying to do the
math in my head.
Trying to figure out when was the
last fucking time this guy got laid?
There's another great stereotype.
If you're some fucking smart nerd,
that means you don't get late in life.
That's bullshit.
It's only in fucking high
school, you know? I Dunno,
is it, I don't even know if it's
fucking true. I just figured, you know,
when you get smart,
if it's really smart and you're good
at business and that type of shit,
you go out and make money in the second
you make money, what's going to happen?
A bunch of fucking cons are
gonna come out of the woodwork.
Who wouldn't have fucked you back in the
day because you couldn't throw a ball
through a fucking hoop.
You know?
That's what that twats wanted to vacuum
up when they were in high school.
The now all of a sudden look at you,
you invented a fucking Hula
Hoop or whatever the hell
you did and now they want
to bang you.
Okay?
Right. Isn't that how it
works? Anything? I am flailing.
Yeah.
I'm walking around.
Why do I feel like I have to make it 50
minutes spill if you don't have anything
to say, fucking bail.
Um, let me hike this. Um,
the m m m m podcast.com is the fan page,
the official fan page,
the only one that I sponsor, www. The MLM,
podcast.com. It's the only one that I,
that I did. Well, who's kidding? Who?
It's the only fucking one there is,
but it's the only one that I sponsor.
I'm trying to make it sound more official.
Um, but anyways, I think there is that,
the podcast for this week.
I'm literally laying on my back right
now just staring at the ceiling wondering
where it all went wrong. Do I have
anything left to talk about? Oh,
I got something for you. Somebody
sent me an email. Let me,
let me just reach for this fucking Straw.
At this point,
somebody sent me an email and it said
overrated in the subject line and then I
open it and it said the Beatles
and then underneath that he wrote,
yeah, I said it. Okay.
Let me tell you something right now.
What?
Like how much I fucking
hate people who go, yeah,
I said it.
You know like this shocking you.
Like they're going after some
sort of fucking, you know, taboo.
Okay.
If you're ever in a comedy club, all
right. And there's a comedian on,
on stage and they, they're
allowed one. Yeah, I said it.
If they do any more than that.
Yeah.
You have my blessing to start
throwing shit at them. I hate that.
That fucking false dangerous
fucking horse shit.
Fucking bitches need to get a job.
What asks say ass shit.
You guys can't handle the truth.
You keep fucking going. Yeah, I said
it. What? I said it, but it's like dude,
nobody in the crowd is going. Who
said that? Did you say that? Yeah,
I said it. You know what I mean? Like,
like they're being let out and
fucking let out and fucking handcuffs.
When will people realize that
nothing is shocking? You know,
look at the fucking Catholic Church.
Look what the fuck they're doing.
You know what is more shocking than that?
The fact that they fucking
look the other way.
Cause I understand why
they look the other way.
Cause there's so much fucking
money involved and you know,
to get to the top of any sort of pyramid,
you have to be an ass kissing cunt.
That's basically what it is.
Unless you created it,
unless you created
whatever pyramid there is.
And at that point you
want your ass kissed.
Yeah.
So whenever there's money involved,
they don't give a shit. I,
you know what is the most shocking thing
about all that is that people continue
to go to the Catholic church.
Okay.
Can anybody out there explained
to me how they separate that?
How do you separate that?
How do you still go to the Catholic
Church knowing that they had 16,000 cases?
Those are just the ones that came forward.
16 fucking thousand.
That's the population of a small town.
16,000 fucking rates of children and
you still go and you give them fucking
money. What do you think they're
going to use that money for?
Lawyers to get these fucking guys off.
You know?
I don't know.
Okay.
Why don't I go Jesus
Christ. Why? Why Bill? Why?
Why do you go down that fucking
road? All right. You know what?
I'm really off my fucking game. Okay.
Pate manning threw an interception.
The final fucking drive of the Superbowl.
This is my,
this is my fucking Peyton manning
Superbowl game right here. Cause this,
this podcast,
was it disjointed cluster fuck
and I really have nothing done.
I really think I was going
to come here and I was,
I had a little information
about Avocados and uh,
what is the United Kingdom when I was
somehow going to be able to fucking talk
for 50 minutes.
Do you realize like when you guys,
you get your,
you have to understand is the level of
fucking ego that it takes that I can look
at three different things and think
that I could run my fucking mouth for 50
minutes. It's not, this is
even the podcast anymore.
This is my confession scene that I didn't
get to do because they're retooling
it. All right. You broke me down.
It's fucking over. You got me.
I have nothing left.
I bought the box set of the wire
just looking at mom around my room
trying to come up with something.
My voice gets weaker
and I watched the first fucking season
and that's a fucking great TV show,
but I'm not going to be
one of those guys who goes,
it's the greatest TV show ever.
It's fucking good.
It's a really good show. I
like it. I like it a lot. Did.
I gave a spelling test
and I really do that.
on the fucking podcast.
All right. You know what? I'm going to,
I'm going to bow out gracefully right now.
Okay? If you want, I add, I
added a date. Here we go. Let me,
let me actually use this podcast.
What I really want to use it for,
my ulterior motive here is the height.
My goddamn dates.
I got some new dates out there.
Everybody.
Let's go to the official website of
Bill Burr is doing officially one of the
worst podcasts ever. Um,
this week in Los Angeles,
April 3rd at the Gibson [inaudible]
theater. Um, I'm doing the,
uh, Kevin and being a
cancer show show for cancer.
Hey, let's get rid of the
cancer. Everybody. I believe
that's the name of it.
It's a fucking benefit for cancer.
Um,
I'm going to get the punch line in
Atlanta, April 8th, ninth and 10th,
and I'm hanging around the 11th.
I have tickets for the finals,
not the final is the final
day of the masters. We,
another buddy of mine are going down
there cause we knew tiger woods will was
going to play. We fucking knew it. Okay.
Who's kidding? Who? You know he's sick.
A Bang in that broad. That's why you
fucked around on her. It was her fault.
She stopped them. You know,
she wasn't washing the dishes,
she didn't make sandwiches
for them anymore.
She started taking tiger for granted and
tiger was sitting there and his billion
dollar lazy boy.
And he's like,
is this bitch take and tiger woods the
greatest fucking golfer of all time?
Yeah,
actually isn't Jack
Nicklaus Jack Nicklaus is,
but she's taken me for granted. Fuck
this. I'm going to go fuck a whore.
That's the one thing that I hated about
that story is how they just never blamed
her for his fucking around
because it was clearly her fault.
Yeah.
And if you're wondering why
I'm coming up with that,
I'm just using the F, you know, it's um,
I'm saying it because of my
respect for females, you know,
because I respect you guys so much
that I'm actually using your train of
thought.
When you look at,
when you see a woman get
caught cheating and you always,
you always blame the guy.
Well it's funny cause he wasn't paying
attention to or it's probably because he
was doing this.
It's probably because he was doing
well the shoe's on the other foot,
you know,
they never say it's cause she
wanted to go out and get some Dick.
Now they have a cause of that cause
it's something that guy was doing.
He left his shoes in the fucking kitchen
after she'd fucking mopped the floor.
So therefore she had to go to the fucking
Luxor and collapse on somebody else's
cock. Right. It's her fault.
You know, where the fuck does she get
off getting mad at fucking tiger woods.
Do you even have a fucking job woman?
What is your job to go around?
Go Dog fucking Tannen. Yeah.
What are you going to do?
I love these fucking twats who are
married to some unbelievably rich person.
Okay?
They have kids with them and they don't
have a fucking job and they still get
help. Still got to have some
fucking, you know nanny.
It's like,
do you want to fucking do anything?
I tell you that that's the guy's fault.
If you marry a fucking woman who
you're making so much goddamn money,
all right that they don't even have a
fucking job and they still need help.
You need help with doing nothing.
I'm raising kids
that are dirty with the foot. My Mother
did that and at a job, you're lazy.
Twat get off the Goddamn Sofa.
That's what I would do.
I take a right across my knee and pull
off her fucking Gucci flip flop and I'd
fucking paddle or right butt cheek until
she admitted how fucking wrong she was.
What do think about that? Maybe that's
why I'm not a billionaire, you know,
cause that's how I do it. John Papa
Razzi would take a picture of it.
I do that paddle a little fucking
right, Fannie. As I had grapes
and then when they questioned
me, I just, we fucked you.
The God Damn Golfer in the world.
Okay,
thanks to me.
Your Sundays aren't boring.
Okay,
come here. Come over here. I'll fucking
sign your camera for you. All right.
Take the film out as no film anymore.
It's fucking digital, right? I Dunno.
I want somebody who embrace being a
piece of shit. That's what I want.
That's what I got to say there.
Tiger Woods wife is a lazy fucking Twat.
All right?
And that's why he cheated on her.
And I'm going to tell you this right now.
The reason why he's playing the
masters is because they need the money.
All right? This guy is at work since
November and I know what you're thinking.
Oh God, it, well, he's a
fucking billionaire. Yeah.
And he's living the lifestyle of a
billionaire. Do you think he wants to?
Of course he does. And he's got
to keep that fucking whore happy,
you know?
Do you think she, who do you think
paid for all the fucking window?
She smashed with that golf club,
right?
I like how we denied that shit in that
attack me with a golf club. Really?
Your windows exploded and then you
drove into a tree where you fucking on
mushrooms. Did you think you
could drive into that little?
Not In the center of the trunk.
Tiger me a fucking break.
What are you sticking up for?
You know why?
Because he married her the fucking idiot.
Now he's got this contract.
You can't get ease. He's looking
to lose all the fucking idiot.
I hope. I hope she listens
to this. I don't even know
our Goddamn name. You know?
I don't know your name sweetheart, because
you never did anything with your life.
You know was the last time you even
fucking, you have even when a swim meet.
What about the preschool level?
When kids are just happy,
they can even fucking stand up.
Did even when a ribbon,
what have you ever done
besides suck the Dick
suck the Dick of the greatest golfer
of the last 50 fucking years other than
Jack Nicholas. You know, that's your big
accomplishment in life. Oh, your hurt.
Let me ask the fellows a question.
Let me ask you this,
what have you was shacking up
with fucking Oprah like Stedman.
Do you think he gives a fuck
if she fucks around on him?
Got to chase him down this or
down the street with a ladle.
Some other fucking utensil.
Cause you know Oprah be eaten right?
You think he'd flipped? I wouldn't give
a shit gon fuck whoever you want. Oprah.
I don't give a shit.
Can I have another car?
That'd be awesome. What are
you doing today? Nothing.
Do Nothing.
Well he fucking Xbox that pitches
doing what everybody wants to do.
Absolutely fucking nothing. You
want to be. Why don't we work?
We work so we can. We can have one
zillions of what that bitch has.
She has the nerve to get mad at this
guy because he's out there banging some
fucking skank
cause he's tired of her fucking lazy ass.
The fuck is wrong with people.
Why not the one out what I said it
say it? Yeah, she's fucking lazy.
Anytime you see a guy fucking around
on his woman, I'm telling you.
Yeah.
Part of it is because he's a dog.
The other part is because
these women are so fucking,
they'll just lazy
the,
it's like they're not even human.
They're just slothful.
Do you know they just sit or religious?
Fucking laying around.
Get off your ass is all you.
You want us to stop fucking around you?
Get off your fucking lazy ass
is what do you think about that?
All right. That's 49 minutes.
Here we go. Sorry. Sorry. Sorry.
I'll fucking women out there. Somebody
had to go down so we had to get hurt.
You know I had nothing. I was
flailing. I was on the fucking ropes.
What'd you want from me?
All right.
49 minutes and 31 seconds. I
have another fucking, uh, oh,
I didn't finish hype and my gigs.
Let me finish typing my gigs. Um,
I just added a date.
I'm going to be in a
Cincinnati via Newport,
Kentucky. I'm going to be at
the funny bone. All right,
so why don't you all you fucking rednecks
get or didn't and come down to the
fucking club. All right. Now.
I know I'm not going to be standing there
and overalls with a fucking piece of
work.
[inaudible] hanging out of my teeth going,
yeah,
we're try to shoot a
fucking pen and you're gone.
That's crazy.
Ain't a fucking kid car criteria.
I know.
I'm not going to be knowing that.
Why don't you broaden your
fucking horizons? All right.
God damn pig fuckers. When are you guys
going to come into the 21st century? Um,
where am I going to be after?
Um, oh, I'm going to be
at the, uh, the Wilbur,
the Wilbur Theater in Boston.
Jody's got to be at the fucking Wilbur.
I'm at.
We actually added a date on May 6th,
and for some reason it's not up on my
site. May 6th and May 7th, May 8th,
and it'll be at the Taj Mahal in
beautiful downtown Atlantic city.
And when I think a glamour,
I think of Jersey, um,
I'm going to shit on every
fucking place that I'm playing.
All You Jersey shore scumbags going to
come down there with your fucking track
suits, Huh? Oh look.
Like some grease stuff.
Fucking $6 million, man.
You're not impressing me.
Chicks with your big fucking Olympic
sized Jody Watley who bearings.
I know that's not real gold. Just
like you're Tan. It's fucking fake.
Come on down. Uh, what else do I got a,
I got a Gig in a,
in Los Angeles at the Hollywood improv.
All right, well how do I
shit on this? I live here.
Come on. You phony. Fuck
out. It's all been done.
How about some of the fucking Mexicans
show up? You know, Jesus Christ,
80% of the population.
You figure you could send a fucking crew
to come down there and represent your
people. Starting to think you guys
don't like me. What? Did I ever say?
Bad about Mexico? Nothing. And you know
why it's cause I haven't read about it yet
and that's it. Then. Don't be a Caroline's
in June. I'm going to be in Montreal,
Canada. You know, I love that.
That's like the minor league for Paris.
That's what that shit is. You know,
all those silly little French guys going
up there acting like they don't speak
English, you know, with
their pointy noses. You know,
they all get that.
Wayne Gretzky face and their little
feathered mullets like run, do gay,
you know I'm going to be coming up there.
You know what sucks is every time I do
Montreal, it's never during hockey season.
So I haven't been to their new,
their new place sucks. Anyways,
I actually went to the
old forum in March of 89.
You can fucking look this up too,
because I remember they played
the Minnesota north stars.
I was at that game and uh,
and I had a good time.
And that's the podcast for this
week. Everybody. Do you see that?
We had a spelling test.
I talked about Avocados and I went
off on the broads for like 10 minutes.
There's your podcast
for this fucking week.
I'm really hoping I w w w that
we get everything ironed out.
I'm sick of saying this. I don't know
what the fucking problem is. All right,
but I'm the talent. All right. I'm
not on the computer side. Okay.
That's not up to me. I don't call the
place. All right. I got a headset on.
I just fucking execute them. Alright.
I'm responsible for on field shit.
Not this behind the scenes stuff.
So send all your complaints to Bill Burrs,
web guy at www dot
[inaudible] dot com backslash,
what the fuck? All capitals. All
right, I'll talk to you next week.